back from lunch before we get this
session started I want to make a quick
announcement we have a slight change to
the schedule tomorrow we will have a
discussion and open problem session this
was supposed to be after the coffee
break tomorrow but we'll do it before
um so this will be 2 45 to 3 45 pm
tomorrow and uh then we will basically
conclude the workshop with tea time at 3
45
and uh the idea for this session is we
will
um we are you're all invited to bring
you know directions and connections
between social applications and uh
sequential decision making which has
been the theme of this uh program uh and
if you want to talk about uh something
uh you know in five to ten minutes
present a new direction or a new model
or just some question up for discussion
you're very welcome to do that uh please
just approach one of the organizers
myself or Irene or Rachel and let us
know that you're interested in speaking
and we'll add you to the schedule uh
okay and without further Ado let me
introduce our next speaker Lydia Liu
Lydia just finished her PhD at Berkeley
right here and now she's a postdoc at
Cornell and she also happens to be on
the job market this year
um so she will tell us about her work on
fairness
yeah thank you so much uh am I Audible
great uh yeah thank you so much once
again to the organizers for this
fantastic workshop and for inviting me
to speak here
um I've really enjoyed the programming
so far so today I'll be talking about
some things that actually I think
um has a lot of resonances with the
talks we've been hearing
um this past week so I will begin this
talk by reviewing the problem of
fairness and machine learning uh
specifically in the context of
algorithmic risk scoring and motivate
and lead up to how fairness is
formalized as various statistical
criteria and I also talk about the
limitations of statistical criteria and
that should set up the next part of the
talk which is about the model a model
that we developed called the model of
the late impact for characterizing the
downstream welfare implications of using
fairness criteria and this is Joint work
with Sarah Dean esteroth Maxim kuwitz
and maritz heart from 2018
and then I will spend a bit of time at
the end talking about full-up work and
interesting future directions and
broader impacts of this way of thinking
about fairness and machine learning
so folks here
um many of you are experts in this so I
kind of don't need to be late believe at
the point but many consequential
decisions in society have started to
depend on algorithmic risk scoring and
some examples of this in credit in the
credit sector obviously credit scores as
a measure of credit risk and being used
to make many lending decisions uh and
the in the criminal criminal justice
setting there are pre-trial risk
assessment tools they're being made used
to make detention decisions and also a
number of other decisions that
Correctional agencies and in the
education setting and interesting
application has been predictive scoring
for students to determine University
admissions decisions so these are a
variety of different positions that are
very consequential but they're being
made at least in part using an algorithm
and the often cited Promises of using
this kind of decision making is to avoid
the arbitrariness of human decisions and
also to utilize information that's
available
um to improve these decisions right and
this is backed by some studies on either
the arbitrariness and judge decision
making that's one example where there
can be a potential Improvement and also
it has been found that credit scores
have led to increased credit access by
providing this additional information
for some households that did not have
access before
but on the other hand there are serious
concerns about the fairness of such
algorithmic decision making first
algorithms can still make systematically
biased assessments and even if when
we're using an algorithm there's
arguably no evidence or no intent to
actively discriminate it can still lead
to disparate impact so the spirit impact
doesn't require active income but as you
as we have known in the pre-trial risk
assessment setting there has been
well-documented evidence of disparate
impact
using this algorithmic risk course and
I'll actually talk more about it in the
next few slides
so we know that algorithmic bias can be
a problem but how do we formalize it and
what are the forms it can take so I am
going to set this up in a classification
context we have a number of individual
decision-making subjects and they have
features X and there is a binary
decision that we want to make based on
the score R of X and there's a true
outcome associated with each individual
I denote that as Y and in this
particular setting we care about a
notion of fairness with respect to a
protected group attribute and that's
denoted a so this notion of protected
groups
um
comes from kind of the legal literature
of certain groups that um
institutionally discrimination against
them is outlawed so I'm going to think
about this algorithmic bias mostly as a
as a group notion
and one example of how this setup can be
instantiated is in the credit setting if
I have features such as an individual's
credit history R would be their credit
score the position I'm trying to make
here is to approve a loan or not to
approve a loan and the actual outcome is
whether that loan is
repaid on time and this
the group attribute there I care about
preventing bias against is this
attribute of race
okay so now I'm going to summarize the
different ways we can formalize
algorithmic bias but essentially they
all have to do with different types of
dependency between the decision or the
score and this protected group attribute
so the most basic
um
issue that might come up is that the
decision that is being made all the
score is group dependent so a complaint
of this nature would be the loan
approval rates are actually a different
by group so in this group you're
approving loans at a much higher rate
than another race group and this is um
this is a form of algorithmic bias where
here I'm expressing it in terms of this
conditional mean Independence
um and in the literature it has been
referred to as demographic parity or
statistical parody so this idea that the
um scores uh the decisions or the or the
scores are group independent
so we noticed that demographic parity
actually says nothing about the quality
or the accuracy of the decisions right
so it's not um taking into account what
the true outcome y actually is and there
are also other forms of bias that
actually takes into account the outcome
so decisions
um here we care we might also care about
whether the false positive or false
negative rates of these Physicians are
group dependent
and this very
concrete example of this is in
um the republicus study of compass
pre-travel risk assessment scores where
they found that for different race
groups the falls and false positive and
false negative rates were actually
different so here you can see that for a
white offender if they were labeled
lower risk
um they actually more of them did re-off
fan then for African-American offender
and similarly for the false um false
positives so here um in the literature
we might say that the decisions violate
equalized odds and uh for the scores
there's
um an analogous notion which is
violating separation
and scores may also be considered biased
if they're not calibrated to the
probabilities of the actual outcomes
so here one concrete complaint might be
for the same credit score one group is
more likely to repay than another group
so the scores actually don't imply the
same probabilities of outcomes for
different groups and here we say there's
a violation of a predicted value parity
um when we're just talking about binary
positions
so all these violations that I have kind
of listed here can reasonably be
considered algorithmic biases and what
this um this kind of formalization has
achieved is that it has turned an
intuitive notion of fairness into
something that we can mathematically
formalize and check and also achieve
algorithmically and so all of these
things can be achieved algorithmically
by post-processing a risk score that but
the issue actually is that we cannot it
turns out we cannot achieve all of them
simultaneously and the I think various
talks before might have also alluded to
this kind of impossibility so what
exactly is this issue here is that um so
for example we want the decisions to
satisfy predictive value parity which is
this notion of calibration
and we also want them to satisfy equal
tpr and fpr and it turns out that this
is only possible in a very restricted
setting where either you can make
error-free decisions so your decisions
um is exactly equal to the true outcome
or you have equal group based rates
right so each group has to have online
has to have has to have on-time loan
repayment at the same rate for this to
be even possible and this was due to
shoulder cover 2016 and the same
impossibility applies to this course as
well so if we want the scores to be
calibrated and also satisfy separation
this is also
um basically impossible unless under
these very restrictive circumstances
and another perspective on this is that
in machine learning we typically care
about scores minimizing population error
right and that's another objective
um that we are very good at optimizing
and it turns out that the
um idea of minimizing population error
is more or less compatible with getting
scores that are calibrated by group
um and this is nice in the sense that
you kind of get calibration for free in
a lot of circumstances but the more the
scores violate the more the scores
minimize population error the more it
turns out that they violate separation
and this can actually be bounded by how
far you are from this very nice regime
where you have error-free decisions so
this degree of violation of Separation
can be bounded by how unequal the base
rates are and how noisy the outcome Y is
by group and similar similar story for
demographic parity
so all this
um combination of results is telling us
that there are varying degrees of
incompatibility between fairness
criteria that we can formalize and this
um we should not take it to mean that
fairness itself Fair decision making
itself is impossible to achieve but that
we have to question if achieving one of
these concrete fairness Notions is
actually the right approach to entering
fairness in a broader sense of decision
making
so what we see in these kinds of
statistical fairness criteria is that
Notions of algorithmic bias are
essentially all statistical they look at
the picture static picture of the
statistical correlations between risk
scores and group attributes and outcomes
but they do not take into account the
downstream impact that these decisions
that are made can have on the protected
groups or on the groups that we're
actually concerned about so one approach
we can take is to model the downstream
benefits or harms of the fairness
interventions and this is what we
subsequently in this work that I'm going
to talk about we call this the delayed
impact and we can use this analysis of
Downstream benefits or harms as a basic
task of whether that fairness notion is
appropriate for this decision-making
context foreign
and this is the work that I'm going to
discuss going forward
so I want to First illustrate the
intuitive idea of the late impact with a
stylized example of lending decisions
so here I'm showing you um two
distributions of credit scores in two
different groups
right and I've alluded to credit scores
as being used by banks for Lending
positions before so here the coloring is
not really to scale but let's just say
at higher credit scores the probability
of repayments higher so greater
proportion of people repay so the solid
circles are people who would actually
end up repaying their loans at that
score and the empty circles are people
would would not end up repaying their
loans at that score right and here the
blue group is actually the group with
lower credit scores on average and we're
going to think of them as a group with
historically lower access to social
Economic Opportunity so now
um I want to do a thought experiment
which is the bank is going to try to
make lending decisions for these two
groups with some kind of fairness in
consideration
and one option one First Option they
have is to apply this demographic parity
criteria which is to equalize the loan
approval rates in each group so we want
to accept the same fraction of loan
applicants in each group so if we accept
that 40 approve 40 of loans and
um the blue group we have to do the same
in the orange group right and the bank
in this case will therefore pick the
loan approval rate uh for both groups
which has to be the same subject uh but
but um to maximize their profit subject
to meeting this demographic parity
constraint
uh just a side note this would actually
not be possible in the U.S from a legal
perspective because it will actually
require a group dependent um thresholds
that we've talked about in yesterday's
talk um by um Swati that this this would
be a problem but we are going to do a
thought experiment or we might imagine
that we're in a less uh strictly
regulated credit sector where this is
actually possible
um from
um like a social welfare kind of
perspective
and a variation of demographic parity
that we might consider is to equalize
the conditional loan approval rates and
this is
um a notion of algorithmic fairness
that's been called equal opportunity and
it says that conditioning on the
repaying applicants only I want to make
sure I have the same loan approval rates
for those repaying applicants
so this is a slightly different criteria
than the bank's decision policy but is
essentially also a constraint so they
would the bank would maximize their
profit subject to this constraint and of
course the bank could also choose to
ignore these constraints and just
maximize their profit and in a way that
is also you can also think of that as an
another a different notion of fairness
or different notion of position making
so suppose the bank uses demographic
parity to make this decision and it
picks group dependent thresholds for
each group so that the same fractions of
loan uh same fraction of loans are
approved in each group and now we
approved the loans in everyone who's
above that black line in their
respective groups and
then the applicants who got the loans
they would end up either repaying on
time or I'm not repaying on time or in
this case we think of it simply as
either they repay or they default at a
particular time so if after this happens
the credit scores of the applicants
actually change as a result you tend to
have your credit scores get lower if you
default on your loan and your credit
scores uh increase by a certain amount
if you repay and you show show the
ability to repay these loans right so on
a group level the scores actually got
worse on average for the blue group and
the scores got better on average for the
orange group so this is arguably harmful
to the group that was already lower
scoring because they have more debt and
less access to Credit in the future so
as a measure of welfare the the blue
group actually has worse future welfare
and we call this population change in
score the delay impact this might be
surprising because we might have
expected the fairness constraints to
kind of promote the benefit of the least
Advantage group but it's not true when
you look at the future credit scores so
now I'm going to describe our model more
precisely and characterize when exactly
fairness constraints might lead to this
kind of harmful delay impact
so us scores as I've said previously is
basically we treat it as a scalar random
variable
um with a certain range of values and
any group of individuals has a
particular distribution over scores and
the scores should correspond to
individual success probability once
there are accepted so once they're given
a loan the probability of repaying the
loan and we assume that they're equally
calibrated for each group and also we
have to assume that the is more the
probability of repayment is monotone in
this course
and later I'll talk about when what
happens if
um this they're not equally calibrated
for each group
the institution has to make a decision
which is to choose an acceptance
threshold for each group
um to to decide who who gets a loaner
who doesn't get a loan and this is
chosen to maximize the bank's expected
utility the expected utility of the bank
is their reward from repayment minus the
loss from defaults and um taking
expectation over the randomness and the
repayment events
and uh we can say there's a one-to-one
correspondence for every uh group
between the threshold applying that
group and the acceptance rate of that
group
so uh going forward I'm just going to
talk about decisions in terms of this
acceptance rate beta
and when there are multiple groups I've
mentioned that the thresholds are
necessarily group dependent uh if I want
to satisfy
um some of the fairness criteria
the scores of the accepted individuals
change depending on their success so the
um this we're going to model this as a
simple
um like linear like an additive change
so the new credit score is
um the oppress core plus a certain
amount if they repay their loans and
minus uh plus a negative amount if they
default on their loans
and the average change in score in each
group is the metric that I care about as
a measure of future welfare and that's
what we call the delayed impact so it's
the difference between the new and the
old scores average across that group
and the first um
first kind of technical characterization
we can say about the delay impact is
that it's a concave function of the
acceptance rate and under mild
assumptions what what are these
assumptions is based the assumptions
basically that the change in score is
the expected change in score is monotone
in the score itself
and uh under that assumption I can
um basically uh characterize what
happens with different
um acceptance rates right so this curve
is showing that as my acceptance rate
increases from zero to one in the group
how does the delayed impact actually
change so if a bank doesn't care about
applying a particular fairness criteria
they only want to maximize their profits
so then the profit maximizing beta
actually results in a particular delayed
impact here so we're going to say that
whatever delayed impact is achieved by a
policy that is worse than the bank's
profit maximizing policy or the bank's
utility maximizing policy that is going
to be considered a regime of relative
harm because the delay impact on that
group is worse than under pure profit
maximization and if um you're actually
doing better than this maximum utility
policy that we call it a relative
Improvement because the delay impact is
like higher than under a profit
maximizing policy alone and the highest
point that you can achieve is with this
maximum this welfare maximizing data so
you have
um this is where the delay impact is
maximized and another regime of interest
is that you are actually causing active
harm by actively reducing the um delay
impact for that group so this is what we
saw in that little example earlier that
the credit scores in the future got
worse on average and these are the three
kind of outcome regimes that I care
about
um
characterizing
so since we know that the delay impact
of a decision policy just depends on the
acceptance rate now what we have to do
to characterize the delayed impact for
each fairness constraint is to
explicitly derive the acceptance rates
but uh one issue here is that the
acceptance rate that is profit
maximizing subject to certain
constraints for the bank depends in
General on the score distributions and
the population proportions in that group
so
um
foreign
we need these characterization theorems
to say what is the beta that achieves a
particular furnace constraints given
these score quantile functions and
population proportions and for equality
of opportunity this also additionally
requires us to know the map row which is
the map from scores to repayment
probability
but given these characterizations is now
very straightforward for us to
characterize what kind of outcome
regimes are possible under fairness
constraint so as a corollary the first
first thing first order information we
can say is that all the outcome regimes
are possible under all the fairness
criteria so equality of opportunity and
demographic parity can cause relative
Improvement relative from or active harm
of in terms of the delay impact and and
contrasting this against unconstrained
utility maximization which never causes
active harm and I should say there's a
star here under the assumption that the
bank's utility
um the ratio of the banks you uh change
in utilities somehow more stringent than
the individuals change in score
oops
and that that assumption there captures
kind of the
um risk adverseness of the bank in a
sense
um
so all the regimes are possible but
however if we wanted to compare the two
fairness criteria in terms of what is
there what tends to be their behavior um
in terms of Shifting the acceptance rate
over um the utility maximizing beta we
can also
um make some general observations of
that nature so the second cholera
corollary is that demographic parity as
a fairness criteria may cause active or
relative harm by over acceptance so by
by accepting
um more by accepting more individuals
from a group than is
um optimal in terms of delayed impact
but equality of opportunity as a
fairness criteria would not have the
same behavior so demographic parity
might lend you in this active harm
regime but equality of opportunity uh
would always be kind of
um lower
um on on that end and it would not
result in active harm by over acceptance
however equality of opportunity can
cause a different type of harm which is
relative harm by under acceptance and to
see that in this picture here is that
it's there are some score distributions
or a class of score distributions that
we can come up with where equality of
opportunity actually accepts fewer
individuals than the utility maximizing
policy and this is
um
not possible with demographic parity as
a criteria
so we know that demographic parity tends
to over accept and we might wonder if
over acceptance is ever a good thing in
terms of the delayed impact so to see
this we consider a situation where the
institution actually has calibration
errors so it means that the bank
systematically underestimates the
repayment ability or the repayment
probability of a particular group so for
the orange group if they have a 0.8
probability of repaying the loan their
assigned credit score of 700 say but for
the blue group with the same probability
of repaying a loan they're actually
assigned a lower score so you can see
there's this calibration error of about
100 in terms of the credit score and if
this is systematically true in the group
then actually over acceptance we might
intuitively think of that as a good
thing right and this is because if the
scores are systematically underestimated
then the acceptance rate for that group
will be lower
for that group and there's something can
concretely prove that is true for
unconstrained utility maximization is
true under demographic parity and also
is true for equality of opportunity
under an additional criteria
so if scores are sort of systematically
miscalibrated then it changes the
acceptance rate for that group and
um and it's lower than if the scores
were actually reflecting true
probability
so here
um for utility maximization you can see
that oops
[Music]
it's now causing relative harm if I just
use utility maximization with these
miscalibrated scores but for demographic
parity
um it's actually maybe a good thing that
it oversaps because it corrects the
error that comes from this
miscalibration
yeah so this might be one consideration
for um which fairness criteria would
kind of resolve a particular kind of um
error in the data or like a like an
upstream miscalibration error so it's
kind of like a downstream way of
resolving that issue
so um I'm just going to show very
briefly what the outcome curves might
look like with a real data so we did an
estimation of the media there's a
question online yes I read it out it
says are the results of delayed impact
relying on the inconsistency of
well-being and utility function of
Institute also in reality you may not
know the exact form of well-being so
this kind of harm to well-being is
inevitable in general
yeah um right that that actually really
hits the
um it really hits the mark in terms of
what the core tension here is right so
um as you can also see in these plots
you can see that like the
um welfare maximizing
um the welfare maximizing decision here
uh for the group is misaligned with
whatever maximizes the bank's utility
under these various fairness criteria
right so but I think that's exactly the
right observation uh is that your
fairness criteria might be doing
something to change the utilities
objective right is the constraints
basically we are shifting the utility
the the decision makers objective but it
might not shift in the direction that
will maximize this appropriate notion of
welfare and of course the problem of
what is the appropriate notion of
welfare is a difficult one it kind of
depends on the context so in this case
um we offer like a particular notion
based on
um this this credit score motivated by
this credit score example but you might
think that like estimating that is like
a whole other issue right so even when
we're trying to
um do this
um semi-experimentally we had to plug in
um profit and loss ratios and the kind
of impact of repayment and default on
the scores so the welfare function in
this case
you can kind of
um if you were actually concerned about
this in practice you probably should
work a lot harder to figure out what is
the right notion of welfare but here I
think for this particular purpose we're
interested in characterizing what is
possible given a particular notion of
welfare and we can see the observations
are kind of happening in a large enough
regime that you can see like active harm
being a possible regime when you apply
demographic parity and I think it's
[Music]
um
basically showing like this is possible
in practice and and not uh so
unreasonable to consider yeah I'm not
sure if that answers the question but I
totally agree with the point
so there has been a lot of um really
exciting and
um related and follow-up work in the
machine Learning Community uh that goes
beyond the static definitions of
fairness but to consider the societal
impact of algorithm algorithmic
decisions more broadly especially in a
dynamic context so some of the questions
that this research area has been trying
to enter include like what happens to
fairness metrics and Welfare metrics
when under long-run population Dynamics
and possible feedback loops between
machine learning algorithms and
populations
um and there's been a lot of great work
on this and um Juba was talking about
earlier today about
um fairness and pipeline type settings
where there are multiple stages of
decision making and this also considers
like long-term
um welfare is that is that 10 minutes or
10 seconds okay
okay yeah and um also instantiating this
idea of long-term Dynamics and for
fairness problems in recommendation
systems and as well very recent work
talked about the delay impact of causal
fairness Notions
and so in terms of practical impact I
think it's also very interesting to
consider how
um this might change the way we evaluate
fairness or real world impact so there
has been
um simulation based toolkits developed
for anticipating this real world impact
of ml systems and um I think one high
level lesson is that these welfare
definitions are hard to pin down but if
we do not actually think about how the
system is run forward we would not know
their the actual impact of the system or
these fairness interventions on the
metrics that we care about so this is
possible made possible by some of the
empirical and toolkit development work
done by Folks at Google research and uh
is the idea of simulation as an
important tool for practitioners has
also been studied
by folks in HCI
so on a broader level I think there's
also been
um a shift in how we talk about
um
AI ethics more broadly so this kind of
theoretical result has actually been
cited in
um in work by philosophers and atheists
who argue for a non-ideal theory of
algorithmic fairness that go beyond
certain static definitions and arguing
for broader assessments of AI ethics in
general so that has opened opened up a
lot of new
avenues for research in those fields as
well
so one um interesting direction that I
have been thinking about recently
um and I noticed as I was thinking about
the talk that the delayed impacts
actually really really nice lens for
thinking about it so the question here
is how do we improve the downstream
outcomes of machine learning and
algorithmic decision making
consequential domains and what um the
this delay impact work has kind of shown
us is that the choice of fairness
constraints in the prediction part of
you know using a machine learning
using a machine learning model
has an impact has a downstream impact on
the stakeholders right but there are so
many other parts of this machine
learning pipeline that have have
particular Downstream impacts and that
this is something that has not been
considered very much until recently so
issues like
um
well the choices in problem formulation
that have a certain delayed impact and
choices and how predictions are
translated into interventions choices in
the goals that we are actually
formulating into machine learning tasks
and so many different choices right and
how we validate the machine learning
positions against the actual goals that
we're trying to achieve so and and a lot
of it also depends on the choice of
metrics so um as a open Direction I
think this opens up like any number of
interesting questions and things that we
can either think about computationally
or we have to think about it more
broadly so in particular
um some collaborators and I in recent
work thought about this in the
particular domain of education and how
machine learning is being used for
education related applications and to
improve the outcome education outcomes
of students and
an important lesson here is that all
those choices are very domain dependent
um and uh I'm very excited to talk about
this work offline uh and but this is all
I have for you today yeah thank you so
much
you have time for questions
not just the last paper looks really
cool talk about it a little bit yeah I'm
sure everyone would want to hear about
it yeah absolutely um so this um so this
paper we actually took um across
disciplinary approach where we had we
conducted these in-depth interviews with
education researchers to talk about
machine learning for Education research
papers so
um the methodology itself was
um like a qualitative research
methodology and
um in terms of the findings it sort of I
put this diagram here because it kind of
summarized what we found we found that
the misalignments between the stated
um so social or educational goals of the
papers and
um the way it was operationalized in
this machine learning pipeline most of
the misalignment actually happened like
not strictly in this machine learning
problem box but in terms of the
translation between predictions and
interventions and the translation
between goals and the Machine learning
problem so
um yeah that's kind of my one sentence
version of that but
more details are available
yeah thank you for the question
okay
thank you very nice talk so I was so I
was wondering about what happens in the
dynamic setting because here you started
out with this assumption that sort of
this course are calibrated through the
outcomes right yeah but then after one
step of executing your procedure the
scores are going to be like reshuffled
and everything is going to be changing
so has it been studied in follow-up work
like what happens if you iterate this
process does it lead to some kind of
like a reasonable equilibrium
Indian
in particular these kind of like two
strategies of
Verity and equality of opportunity yeah
I usually do anything nice
sorry what was that so so if you
consider these demographic parity
inducing and an equal opportunity uh
kind of strategies do these in
particular lead to reasonable equilibria
yeah yeah so the equilibrium perspective
has been studied
um in some of the papers I've mentioned
here but I I think that you're also
referring to this issue that like once
you allow the scores to change are do
they now become miscalibrated or do the
probabilities themselves
change like do we believe that they
actually change the probability in the
real world so that's kind of like a
modeling question there I think that's
very interesting I'm not sure if it has
been studied or if
more insightful stuff has been said
about it I think the in terms of
long-term equilibrium and what is the
successive application of fairness
criteria do is I think there's been some
work that at least looked into that but
maybe not in this exact model right
uh hi thanks for the talk I have a kind
of amorphous question do you have any
um connections or thoughts about uh this
long-term impact with strategic
classification or maybe uh strategic
Behavior by like the company in some way
yeah yeah
um there has been like you probably know
about this like like really nice work
um by different groups on kind of the
downstream costs of using strategic
classifiers I think that's like a well
established area that there are certain
like uh there's unfairness in terms of
the cost that is being imposed on
um groups when or sub-populations when
you um
deploy a classified address that is like
robust to the Strategic manipulation
um type like feature manipulation type
things uh there is also some work that
myself and collaborators have done on
like strategic
um populations where you're instead of
changing features you're kind of
changing like
um your outcome or you're changing your
your investing in the outcome and
um that uh so we had a model that
studied how the long-term qualification
rates evolve over successive
applications of this machine learning
decision making model
um and that's off the top of my head
what I can think about but yeah there's
definitely a lot of interesting
interplay between because Dynamics
happen because there are like sort of
certain incentives to change right so
this can be modeled by strategic players
or it can also be modeled in this more
General framework on performative
prediction that I think Folks at
Berkeley have them so a lot of
interesting different ways of
approaching that question
okay great thank you very much we'll
take the rest of the questions offline
[Applause]